Let's make my mom's chocolate chip cookies.
You're gonna start with a
one cup of shortening of your choice.
I used butter,
one cup of sugar,
and then half a cup of brown sugar.
Cream those together,
which just means to mix them together.
And then we're gonna add two eggs.
I measure vanilla by heart,
but you could probably also do 1 teaspoon.
This was way more than I actually needed by accident.
Mix together,
and then you're gonna add
one and a/2 teaspoons of baking soda.
And then you're also gonna add in another
one and a/2 teaspoon of salt.
Slowly add in the flour. Between 2.
Two and a/2 to 3 cups.
If you want sugar cookies,
use less flour.
If you want dough or cookies,
use more flour.
Add in half a bag of chocolate chips.
Mix that together.
I'm then gonna take my handy dandy cookie scooper,
and I'm going to put those on a baking sheet,
pop those in the oven at 3:50 for 10 to 12 minutes,
and then they will come out the most gooey,
delicious cookies you have ever had in your life.